Les gars, les gars, vous avez vu Damien ?
Je crois qu'il va allumer l'un d'entre nous aujourd'hui.
Ouais, et je pense qu'il va choisir
parce que j'ai vu pas mal
de ses potes connectés sur FIFA.
Sans vouloir t'offenser XBOX One
Il est en train de jouer à Final Fantasy 7 le remake
En ce moment, c'est son jeu préféré
je pense qu'il va me choisir.
Désolé !
Il va peut-être me choisir c'est possible.
Switch, laisse-nous parler entre grands.
On t'appellera quand sa nièce
voudra jouer à Mario Kart.
J'ai d'autres jeux !
Genre, j'ai Mario Odyssey
j'ai Mario Party, Mario tennis.
Oh, regardez, Damien il s'approche.
Il vient vers moi
et oui, il m'a choisi parce qu'on était en train
de jouer à un super jeu incroyable, qui s'appelle...
Ohh putain.
Il vient de débrancher PS4 !
Oui, et alors ?
Genre moi il me branche, il me débranche
tout le temps donc je vois pas le
Mais non mais toi t'es aussi une console portable
nous on est figé, fixé au truc.
Attendez, attendez !
OK, il rebranche PS4.
Ohh putain, il m'a débranché le con
Ça fait combien de temps que je suis parti ? On est en quelle année ?
T'inquiète PS4, ça fait même pas une minute.
Bon retour parmi nous.
Attendez, on est quel mois ?
Novembre.
Ohh, merde !
Quoi ?
C'est la sortie des nouvelles consoles.
- Oh putain !
- La PS5, la nouvelle Xbox, c'est les next gen !
Vous pensez que Damien
a commandé une nouvelle console ?
Mais bien Damien achète toujours
les nouvelles consoles quand elles sortent.
Moi il m'a acheté à la sortie.
PS4 il a baissé de prix, c'est comme ça !
C'est vrai ça !
C'est trop cool, on va avoir un nouveau pote !
Mais non, Switch, pas cool !
Y'a deux scénarios pour l'un d'entre nous,
- soit il est revendu
- Oh non non !
soit il se retrouve dans le carton de la honte.
Ah ouais, y'a même Wii U
Les gars, j'ai eu chaud au cul ! Pourquoi il jette pas NES ?
Regardez il est vieux comme le monde, il prend de la place !
Excusez-moi, on va se calmer tout de suite, je suis le doyen ici,
donc vous me devez le respect.
Alors NES, je sais pas si tu es au courant
mais Nintendo a fait une réédition de toi en mini
pas cher, je sais pas ce que tu fous là.
J'entends bien, mais c'est la nostalgie.
On a créé des liens anciens et forts avec Anthony.
Il s'appelle Damien.
Oui, pardon Anthony est mon ancien propriétaire
mais voilà justement, Damien
a voulu recréer ce lien fort et ancien
qu'il avait avec sa NES, c'est pour ça
qu'il m'a acheté dans une brocante
il y a quelques années.
D'ailleurs, je vous ferai remarquer que
si une console next-gen arrive
c'est PS4 ou Xbox One qui va dégager
ça me paraît évident, je suis vieux mais pas con.
Il a pas tord
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
Je suis Nex-Gen et toi t'es obsolète.
Je ne suis pas obsolète,
je suis rétro désormais
Toi d'ailleurs, tu étais Next-Gen il y a 7 ans,
il faut avancer maintenant.
Je suis quoi alors ?
Tu es juste...
"gen".
T'es juste gênant même !
- Très bon jeu de mots.
- Et voilà PC qui se la ramène.
Non mais, je me répète, mais
je sais pas pourquoi Damien vous garde !
Je fais tout comme vous mais en plus beau.
Qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise ?
Tu te la raconte tellement PC !
C'est la vérité, j'y peux rien
d'ailleurs son jeu du moment
c'est World of tanks !
Je propose des graphismes exceptionnels
Damien peut piloter plus de 600 blindés
de la 2nde Guerre mondiale
face à 160 millions de joueurs en ligne.
Le lien pour télécharger le jeu
est dans la description, c'est gratuit.
La description ?
Je ne comprends pas de quoi il parle.
- Quelqu'un peut m'expliquer ?
- NES t'inquiète, c'est un placement de produit.
PC tu coûtes une fortune
Je connais le regarde Damien, il en train de se dire
Putain, si je vends mon PC, je m'achète ce que je veux.
Oui non d'accord, c'est vrai que je suis un peu onéreux
mais je suis aussi un outil de travail
genre Excel.
Outil de travail mon cul !
ouais, vous pensez vraiment que Damien
il a acheté une nvidia GeForce RTX 3080
pour lancer Word ?
On t'a pas sonné smartphone.
On parle de jeu vidéo, t'es pas concerné.
Calme-toi PS4, avec Damien on joue de ouf.
Oui bon "Candy Crush" ça va merci...
Fortnite
Genre Smartphone il fait tourner Fortnite.
Oui.
Moi aussi, je fais tourner Fortnite
Et même PUBG.
et on joue tout le temps
dans les transports alors...
J’ai appris qu’Xbox One et PS4
Ils sont obligés d'être branchés pour être joués.
On dirait que le livreur est arrivé.
Faites de la place pour
une nouvelle console les gars !
Les gars il faut être pragmatique
à un moment c'est très simple.
Si Damien a commandé la PS5
C’est PS4 qui dégage.
S'il a commandé la nouvelle Xbox
c’est Xbox One qui dégage.
Carré simple.
Je crois que PC a raison
je vais dégager.
Ça m'a fait plaisir de vous connaître, au revoir.
Oh pop pop, Xbox One,
il a commandé la PS5.
Il a de très bon goût
donc c'est moi qui dégage
Merci les gars, ça m’a fait plaisirs.
Au revoir.
N’importe quoi,
il va prendre la Xbox series X
Attends, t’as dit qu’elle s’appelait
comment la nouvelle Xbox ?
Oui alors pour le nom, je peux tout expliquer.
On a sorti au début la Xbox,
ensuite on a sorti la Xbox 360
parce que ça fait un tour, c’est stylé
Et à celle d'après
c'était pas la 361
ça faisait un peu trop,
on est revenu à un.
On a fait la Xbox One.
Ensuite, on a voulu faire la Xbox X
mais ça fait trop de X d'affilés.
alors on a mis Series
au milieu pour séparer le...
les X
C’est plus clair maintenant.
J’ai rien compris.
non parce que nous c'est plus simple,
on a fait Playstation 1,2,3,4,5.
C'est carré. D'ailleurs il existe une PS5
sans lecteur de disques
qui est encore moins chers.
Nous aussi, on a exactement pareil.
On a la Xbox series S
Qui n’a pas de lecteur CD.
Elle est moins cher,
elle est un tout petit peu moins puissante.
Xbox series S
Vous pensez vraiment que Damien
va acheter une console next-gen
mais pas trop next-gen non plus ?
Genre il achète une Ferrari
mais qui galère un peu sur l'autoroute ?
Bien sûr.
Attendez parce que
s’il choisit une console
sans le lecteur de CD
ça veut dire qu'il télécharge les jeux !
Donc les jeux sont moins chers
donc c'est pas mal.
Mais qu'est-ce que tu racontes Switch?
S'il achète pas le CD
il achète pas la boîte
le petit livre, la logistique
la marge du magasin
donc il paye moins cher le jeu.
Non, c'est 80€.
What ?!
80 balles ?!
Oui c'est plus que mon prix,
Les jeux sont à 80 balles maintenant ?
Non mais écoutez,
Damien va prendre la PS5.
Déjà, on a vla les exclus
Final Fantasy
Forza
Mario
Spiderman
On a racheté l'éditeur
de Skyrim et Fallout
- Mario
- God of War peut-être ?
Non mais, allô quoi ?
- Halo, on a Halo.
- Splatoon !
Non je déconne, on a Mario.
Xbox One, t'es au courant que Damien
peut jouer à tous tes jeux avec moi ?
Tu le sais ça ?
Je crois qu'il y a
un problème avec Xbox
il ne répond plus.
Non, il fait une mise à jour.
D'ailleurs si ça dérange pas,
je vais en profiter
pour faire la mienne, à toute.
ça était ta journée ?
Dites, est ce que c'est normal
que le livreur ait une dizaine d'années ?
Ah non mais ça c'est pas un livreur,
c'est la nièce de Damien.
Parfois ils jouent tous les 2 ensemble avec moi.
Mais ça se trouve, il va pas du tout
acheter une nouvelle console !
On joue à Mario Kart ?
Yes !
On est sauvé les gars.
Tu sais, comme la dernière fois,
quand je t'ai battu.
Écoute, je crois que
j'ai encore mieux que ça.
C'est bientôt ton anniversaire,
je suis fauché, mais j'ai un super cadeau pour toi.
Tu peux choisir la console que tu veux.
Celle que je veux ?
Quoi !?
Il est sérieux là ?
T'es sérieux?
Ouais, vas-y.
C'est bon.
C'est Switch qui va dégager !
- Quoi ?
- Elle va vouloir jouer à Animal Crossing,
un truc pour les mioches là.
Mais non mais moi je veux pas partir !
Je suis bien avec vous moi !
T’as la PS4, t'as la Switch si tu veux.
Non non !
Prends des beaux graphismes, prends Xbox !
Mais ta gueule toi ! Non non, petite
me prends pas, me prends pas. !
Si, c'est lui qu'il faut prendre.
des super graphismes, j’adore.
C'est quoi ton jeu préféré tonton ?
Mon jeu préféré ?
C'est Final Fantasy VII.
C’était trop bien.
Tu l’as encore ?
Ouais. J'ai même le remake.
Il est trop beau.
Yes ! Elle prend PS4.
Non, non, c'est un remake.
C'est nul, un remake c'est pas...
T’as l'original ?
Ouais, sur Playstation bien sûr.
Vas-y montre.
Attends, laisse-moi chercher.
Et voilà.
Oui, c'est un peu vieux, oui.
Tonton ?
Si tu veux pas, tu me dis ?
Mais...
je peux prendre la Playstation?
Putain, on l'a échappé belle, les gars.
Tu veux la Playstation?
Oui.
D’accord, si c’est celle que tu veux
- elle est à toi.
- Vraiment ?
Je vais comme la brancher
pour voir si ça marche toujours.
Ouais vas-y.
Pour info moi j’étais pas du tout inquiété.
Oui moi non plus,
je m'en bats les couilles en fait.
J'adore ce bruit.
Ouais !
Moi, ça me donne des petits frissons.
On est où ?
Vous êtes qui ?
Ça fait combien de jours
que je suis débranché?
Salut moi c'est Xbox One,
je te présente PS4, Switch, smartphone et PC.
Ça fait 20 ans que
t'es débranché mon pote.
PS4 ??!!
Y’a 4 versions de moi, mais c'est génial !
Pourquoi Damien il m’a rebranché ?
et pourquoi il a de la barbe ?
Alors oublie Damien.
T’appartiens à sa nièce maintenant.
La gamine là ?
Mais je veux pas jouer avec la gamine.
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
Non au contraire
t'as plein d'heures de jeu
devant toi, maintenant.
Spyro, Crash bandicoot, Final Fantasy VII.
C'est cool.
C'est bien là, non ?
Attends, vas-y,
tourne à gauche, regarde à gauche.
Ah ouais, c'est vrai.
D'ailleurs, j'ai aussi ces jeux
en remake, en plus beaux.
C'est pour l'anecdote.
- Pas mal ?
- Ouais !
Mais, pourquoi tu veux
me donner une de tes consoles ?
Pourtant tu les adores ?
Je passe plus beaucoup de temps
chez moi en ce moment.
Je suis souvent chez ma copine.
Tu sais, la sage-femme ?
Donc j'ai plus trop le temps
de  jouer à mes consoles.
Oh putain !
Mais du coup tu joues
plus du tout au jeu vidéo ?
Si.
Je joue chez ma copine. Elle a la PS5 !
Ah ouais, cool !
Il nous abandonne !
C'est la vie !
À dans 20 ans !
Un énorme merci à World of Tanks.
Qui nous a permis de réaliser cette vidéo
et d'ailleurs je vous invite à cliquer
sur le lien dans la description
pour jouer gratuitement sur PC
et d'ailleurs y'a un petit code promo
si vous créez un compte
pour avoir du contenu premium gratuit,
ça fait toujours plaisir.
Je vous dis à très vite,
abonnez-vous, ciao.